thanks everyone for coming in thanks for
joining us and sharing your views so I'd
like to ask just a few questions for the
first half hour and then we'll kind of
open it up for general Q&A from the
students and visitors so Preet I think
some one thing MBA students sometimes
don't know is that you manage a large
organization with a huge budget many
employees and also the employees that
you have these assistant US attorneys
have a lot of power and discretion so
just want to kind of kick off if you can
share just kind of your views of
management how you manage a larger
organization how you select for people
to ensure that they're going to be
ethical and kind of you know make sure
the organization is doing what it should
be doing
thanks I'm it's great to be here thanks
for having me this is a particularly
comfortable chair I realized so I
apologize I forget if I got too
comfortable people sometimes ask me from
time to time given given what we do and
we prosecute a lot of kinds of cases
including white collar cases some I hate
to say it alums of this very institution
have been have been prosecuted and
people saying why do you come and speak
to groups like this and I say it's
because I really really like the sound
of nervous laughter
thank thank you so so people may not
fully appreciate that as we were talking
about before we came out here that I'm a
lawyer and a prosecutor and that's a
large part of my job but it probably
isn't even the biggest part of my job I
run an institution like a lot of you
will eventually maybe very soon we have
450 employees there abouts we have
personnel issues we have to deal with I
have a budget I have to deal with I have
four different locations I hire on a
regular basis we have a lot of turnover
so a large part of my job is the same
kind of job that any CEO of a company
has which is to make sure that you're
motivating people you're inspiring them
you're retaining them you try to get
them to do the right thing you're trying
to get them to Touro in the same
direction and advance the mission of the
office now that turns out that the
mission of our office is and is always
supposed to be not the manufacturer of
widgets or the provision of some service
other than to the taxpayers who pay our
salary and that is to make sure that we
ensure that justice is done and that
doesn't mean you know just notching
victories on your belt and putting
people in prison but making sure that
the right thing is done in every case
for the right reasons all the time and
so my brother is a business person and
ran a company and is much wealthier than
I am so sold his business to Amazon for
half a billion dollars so he buys dinner
now when we go out um but but as part of
the question you're asking he and I have
gotten together a lot and he ran a
fairly sizable company is starting a new
one now that a lot of the things that we
think about and care about are the same
as I mentioned motivating people and
getting people do the right thing
so the most important thing I think and
I think most business people will tell
you this and I learned it when I took
over in my job is to hire the right
people when we get to hopefully will
talk a little bit about culture and
ethical culture and creative culture
that's all about the people you bring in
there's no system
there's no system that can do the job
there's no structure that can do the job
unless you have the people in the right
place and so I think about my job
sometimes as a lawyer who's involved as
a CEO of an institution sort of a
business and sometimes in the reverse
and I think the same thing about the law
you can't have a good legal structure
and you can't have justice being done no
matter how good your laws are as a
society
or how good your ethical code is as a
company or your strategy is as a company
unless the people who are executing
those things understand it care about it
and are doing it for the right reason so
the number one thing is the people you
hire and the people you promote so just
building on that one thing you've
mentioned is that people that salivate
of putting you know Charlie Sheen and
Michael Douglas in handcuffs are not the
right people to be us eternities
you know cuz those aren't people who are
interested in justice they're actors
right right you know who that this when
they kind of see the movie Wall Street
that's what they dream about those
aren't kind of the right people to hire
so just you know if the and part of that
is the fit of what you care about and
what kind of job you want so what advice
would you give to our students on how
they select a job and what kind of
career that they're gonna do yeah so you
know I've spoken a lot of business
schools including much lesser business
schools in this one and the that was a
compliment to the school and and I'm
astonished sometimes when I hear people
asked you know the question about where
you should go and and whether or not you
should focus more on how much money you
can make it a place and obviously it's
important to think about what the terms
are gonna be in your employment and you
want to make a good living and you want
to do a good job you also want to think
about places where you can grow you also
want to think about places where you can
learn my concern not on the part just of
students who are coming out of one of
the best business schools in the world
but also for everyone for politicians
for prosecutors for for leaders of every
kind is it everyone is always thinking
too often about the next day or the
current fiscal year or the current
budget year for themselves personally
and not thinking about the long-run
and so relevant to my job I say to
people you should think about the
reputation for ethics and integrity of
the place you go and I know that some
people sometimes roll their eyes and
they say well that's a sort of a pie in
the sky view it's not my problem I'm
gonna be a small person going to a
trading firm or going to a financial
institution of some sort you know that's
really not my problem and I beg to
differ with that I think you should
think about what the reputation for
honesty is not only because it's better
to work in a place that is like that and
has a good reputation but also because
you're taking less risk less long-term
risk with your
current implement is asked the people
who worked at the Galleon Group that's a
hedge fund that ended up going under
because a number of people from that
firm were convicted of insider trading
offenses and you know I believe it to be
true that people knew that there was
something off about the reputation of
that place compared to other places and
there are a lot of people at that place
who didn't do anything wrong
who didn't commit any crime but they now
have on their resume the unfortunate
taint of having worked at a place where
there were bad apples so I don't come
here to lecture about morality and
ethics but to also remind you that those
are issues of risk that you have to deal
with I assume that you think all the
time about risk and cost-benefit
analysis because that's what you do in
business school but sometimes ethical
considerations are also important in
that regard too I also think it's the
case that the companies if you cared
about and I know that in Northern
California people care a lot about these
things about the ethic of a place and
the mission of a company and a business
if everybody cared if the labor market
care near the labor market you're the
premier labor market for business in the
country and in the world if you cared
about those things then companies would
care more about making sure that they're
doing things by the book and being
straight up so I'll stop there so what
are some specific things to look for
this is like a person example my first
job out of college was at a New York
financial institution with the initials
GS and at the time they were considered
to blood stock after the most sure you
know okay they were to be the most
up-and-up firm in terms of kind of the
reputation what you know what the
prosecution's looked like in the 80s and
90s and so it's hard to project and they
got in some trouble in recent times so
what are some like specific red flags
you would advise the students to look
for if they're interested in working for
an ethical organization I'll tell you an
easy one the interview process is a
two-way street and I had somebody come
up to me after I talked to a business
class like this one said it's a couple
years ago and said I'd interviewed he'd
interviewed at you know 12 or 13
different firms on Wall Street and only
one firm asked any question that
suggested to the applicant that the firm
cared about the applicants ethics or the
firm
cared about what the applicant thought
of the firm's ethics and I said where
you gonna work and they said I'm gonna
go work at that firm and I said that's a
great that's a great thing um you
shouldn't use the interview process
wherever you go to ask questions of your
own and if you ask a question about how
they think about ethics and how they
think about integrity and how they think
about reputation and how they think
about the long term you'll learn a lot
from your from your question even if you
get sort of a pat answer I'm a big fan
of asking questions and people say you
don't do this in cross-examination of a
witness on the witness stand but outside
of that context I'm a fan of asking
questions even if you know what the
answer is gonna be because you'll learn
a lot and a lot of what you're gonna be
doing is understanding people right as
leaders you'll learn a lot from how long
it takes them to answer and how
uncomfortable they are in how they
answer the question how long it takes
them to answer the question and I give
the same advice
to business people too if somebody asks
you the question when you're hiring by
the way so soon you're gonna be hiring
yourselves you know you want to
perpetuate the kind of integrity and
ethics of the institution that
presumably you went to and if you when
you're hiring somebody ask a question
like here's my favorite questions I
don't think anybody ever asks at least
I've never heard anybody asking it at a
trading firm let me just ask you the
question suppose you come to the firm
and six months from now you say to the
applicant you have reason to believe
you're not sure but you have reason to
believe that the person sitting two
doors down from you maybe is illegally
trading and inside information what do
you do now you will learn there's no
perfectly correct answer to that
question which might surprise you given
what I do for a living but you you will
learn about how that person reasons
morally you will learn if that person
too quickly says well I would absolutely
report to the CEO of the company I want
to call the SEC because that's not
that's BS people are not likely to so
quickly be able to make that decision
and even though it might sound odd to
you for me to say it a person who so
blithely and quickly says that they'd
immediately turn in a co-worker without
full knowledge is not someone you want
to hire either but you're also going to
see if someone seems uncomfortable
you're gonna see if somebody thinks the
answer I that you want me to give you is
that it's none of my business and I've I
don't have proof beyond a reasonable
doubt I'm gonna keep my mouth shut you
don't want to hire that person either so
I think in the higher
process in both directions if people pay
attention and pick up normal human cues
about who is likely to do the right
thing when presented with controversy or
presented with a crisis you want to work
for those people okay just want to pivot
a little bit but stay on this topic of
kind of money as a motivator so you've
kind of prosecuted very prominent people
one I'll just give an example is the
former McKinsey managing director Rajat
Gupta as Dean Rajan mentioned growing up
as an Indian American you know he was an
idol in a lot of ways you know basically
became the head of an old white shoe
consulting firm the most prestigious
consulting firm out there and you know
this person was very wealthy many of the
people that you've prosecuted are
wealthy before engaging in unethical
activity why do you think such
accomplished people cross the ethical
line to make money given that that
really shouldn't be a motivator I'm like
what are your thoughts on that given all
the experiences you've had with these
kinds of folks I don't know I get asked
that question a lot
and I think it's different for different
people I think some people can't help
themselves I think some people are
inherently bad people and inherently
corrupt people the interesting about the
example you give is it's it's one thing
if you ask the question you know why do
people break the law who should know
better to make money a lot of people you
prosecuted including the one you
mentioned is not somebody who you know
was was on food stamps and needed to
make money to survive we're talking
about people many of them who had more
money than you can spend in a lifetime
you know more accolades than you could
ever you know put on your wall in a
lifetime why is it that's why it's a
great question why is it that they were
engaged in absurd criminal activity and
you know people speculate as
psychologists do that often it's the
case that people are not it's not about
making that extra dollar but about it's
about power and it's about becoming even
with other people who were in the class
just above you I mean it's common in the
United States to talk about the
phenomenon of keeping up with the
Joneses but there are different class
classes of Joneses everywhere in the
world it happens you know in the
neighborhood where I grew up in New
Jersey where it was mostly middle class
and apparently as I've discovered in the
last few years it happens at the
absalon's
of
of wealth and power and that's all
speculation you know I don't know the
thing that is important for us to
communicate and for me to make sure that
everybody understands is it's really
it's really not worth it and it's and
it's astonishing to me that there are
people who know better and and know so
much who put their Liberty at risk and
put their reputations at risk when they
didn't need the money so if you have
answers to the question I'd be happy to
hear what you think well well here's one
other thought so one answer you gave is
the difference between relative wealth
and absolute wealth you know another
theory could be that when you get into
these high positions of power just
something psychologically say you don't
think the rules apply to you anymore or
that you don't even believe you're doing
anything wrong or that you're above
these simple things called lis legal
institutions I mean you think that plays
into a role where it's not even a
cost-benefit calculation that's just
yeah look I think there's an arrogance
so there's a lot of Harrigan's both at
the in the public corruption area and in
the corporate corruption area as I think
was mentioned in the intro we've been
charging a number of politicians in New
York and convicting them that people
think the rules don't apply to them
people think that they're very clever
and they can get away with it I think
there's also a little bit The Fault in
some areas can fall on the shoulders of
prosecutors and regulators because if
for a long period of time nobody's
enforcing something people a combination
of arrogance and greed and an aspiration
to power and wealth combined with a lack
of enforcement gets people to think well
not only am i more clever not only is it
okay for me but no one's gonna do
anything about it anyway and the worst
thing that's gonna happen is I get a
fine and I maybe have to disgorge some
of my profits so my cost-benefit
analysis tells me I might as well engage
in the fraud because I probably keep it
all and if not it was not a bad risk
like some other risks that I take it's a
part of our job is to disabuse people
about calculus so if you have like a few
minutes here to disabuse audiences like
this you know and one thing to say is
it's not worth it it's not worth the
risk if you could kind of if you had
like two minutes to kind of build upon
that either you know stories of people
that you know that they kind of realized
after the fact it wasn't worth it that
might kind of drill that home kind of
what would you say yeah so
I say this all the time and when I come
to speak to groups like this it's not
only you know sort of a scared straight
program for a white-collar folks
although it's turning into that and it's
not it's not just and the people who
laugh louder's are the ones i pay
attention to and it's not just to direct
my words of caution you know and maybe
admonition to the two or three of you in
this room who statistically speaking are
likely to commit serious securities
fraud although I know who you are
and we will be following you after the
program it's it's really and this goes
directly to a question it's really to
direct my words and cautions to the to
the ears of the vast majority we're in
this room of the people who are good and
honorable and honest and ethical and
believe themselves to be so and want to
do the right thing and graduate from
Business School wanting to do the right
thing and some of the people you
mentioned I believe had that view and
had that view for a long time and who go
to companies wanting to do the right
thing and then something happens along
the way not necessarily because they're
doing the wrong thing but they see other
things happening and they don't do
anything about it I think the biggest
problem of institutions not just
financial institutions or companies that
make products or that provide services
but universities also and US Attorneys
offices also and legislators also is
that that bad things happen when the
vast majority of good people are
apathetic and stand by and let bad
things happen that's why you have Penn
State that's why you have problems in
sports leagues that we've been talking
about a lot in in the national media
lately and you know there's nothing you
can do about the two or three right
statistically speaking there's always
going to be people who are gonna do bad
things and whose parents didn't teach
them well I suppose but you can survive
that so long as all the good people when
they're in that situation have the
courage and the fortitude to walk to say
something and then walk away or say
something and fix the thing and it's not
it's not easy the biggest problem I've
found in prosecuting cases and the
biggest regret you have when when we
come in basically forensic ly and the
fraud is already by the time we are
involved by the way it's terrible for
everybody because the regulator's have
failed the into
controls that the company has failed and
people are being led away in handcuffs
and the company may collapse but four
years before that they were good people
or reasonably good people who knew a
galleon that something was fishy
who knew at Madoff securities that
something was fishy who knew at Penn
State that young boys were being raped
perhaps and and the great tragedy and
regret you have is that those people
didn't do anything about it and so the
one thing I would say to people like you
in this room we're all of good faith and
good will and want to do the right thing
I absolutely believe that don't let
yourself ever be derailed from that
yourself personally but more importantly
don't let the institution be derailed by
bad people who are trying to bring it
down because a it's the wrong thing to
do and B it's gonna near to your
detriment also so sometimes there's
career risks at doing that right that ya
know that intellectually it's the right
thing to do but we're saying I have a
you know I have a spouse I have kids you
have a mortgage payment there's gonna be
career risks if I kind of stand up for
what's right so what kind of advice
would you give in you know saying in the
long run it's still the right thing to
do even though there might be short run
it's look it's not it's not easy it's
you know I don't when you think you know
Preet Bharara parachutes in he says you
know quit when you have a mortgage to
pay it's not easy there's a reason why
by the way there are two different laws
the United States the False Claims Act
and and dodd-frank which incentivize
whistleblowers to come forward by paying
them a percentage of the money that the
government recovers which would seem to
be crazy if everyone was a fickle and
trying to do the right thing and
sounding the alarm bell when bad things
are happening and the reason you have
that is because it's difficult as a
psychological inhuman matter people you
know they're fit their movies about
people who are ostracized and books
written about people who are ostracized
who rightly blow the whistle and so the
only thing you can do is I think be
aware of that all the time think about
the lessons that you've learned about
bad things that happen to institutions
and banks going under and people being
harmed physically and otherwise and
institutions failing because you don't
do something about it now in the moment
it's not always so easy to do but there
are there are things you can think about
doing in the initial instance as an
initial matter don't just turn your head
away I'm not saying necessarily at the
first moment you feel there's a whiff so
thing bad that's going on that you
immediately go to on 60 minutes but but
it does but it does mean you don't just
you know have a drink and go to bed you
think about it you talk to somebody
about it you talk to a friend about it
you talk to maybe a law school friend
about it you talk to a colleague about
you you do you do something and you
elevate it somehow because chances are
other people think it too and then it
becomes easier if you have a group of
people who say it's hard to go into the
boss's office alone it's easier to go if
there are two of you it's easier still
if there are three of you and who knows
maybe your immediate supervisor also has
that problem and it will take you know
you as the person of courage to finally
provoke something that changes and the
other point of that I'm gonna make is
another problem I think on the part of
young people who are very smart and
talented and do the right thing like
everyone in this room is that you arrive
at a new place you don't know what the
policies are you're not expert in the
law you're not expert in the regulation
and something strikes you as fishy and I
think this happens over and over again
and one way you excuse not doing
anything about it is you see it herself
well what do I know and it's not always
it's partly maybe you think I don't want
to get in trouble and I don't to be
ostracized and I don't want to get fired
and I want to be a troublemaker but
often and maybe this is a self
rationalization but I think sometimes
it's honest you think well what do I
know
these are smart people they seem quite
nice if they think it's okay then they
must be right and that's the moment
where I want you to think about this um
you folks are at Stanford Business
School you're among the smartest most
educated most mature people in the
country I'm willing to bet you a lot of
money that if one day you're from now or
three years from now you think something
fishy is going on you're probably right
and you need to trust your instinct for
that because that's often not about the
particular regulation and the sub part
of the third regulation that just got
enacted it's not about that
I'm talking about when you think people
are acting in a moral and that's why I'm
using the funny word fishy are acting in
a fishy way you are almost always going
to be right about that and you should
pay attention to the voice in your head
that says something fishy is going on
here and don't excuse inaction because
you think well I'm the new guy and I
don't really know all the rules
just want to kind of transition to kind
of you know ethical decisions that
businesspeople make to kind of ethical
decisions that US attorneys make so
Madhava listed a bunch of things your
office is doing I don't even know how
you sleep you sleep at all so in
addition to terrorism financial crime
political corruption has been a major
focus of the southern districts work so
you've sought convictions of both
Democratic and Republican politicians US
Attorney's it's a very interesting
office it's a political appointed office
but they're supposed to be non-political
interactions if people remember a few
years ago this was a big issue in the
bush administration's Justice Department
and you know you think about people who
have kind of been aggressive at rooting
out political corruption and those who
haven't and what the career Awards are
give an example of 2001 I think both
Patrick Fitzgerald and Chris Christie
were appointed as US attorneys I'm
getting that right I think most people
in this room know who Chris Christie is
I doubt that many people remember who
Patrick Fitzgerald was so I guess given
that you know there are some clear
motivations going forward how do you
develop the courage personally in the
conviction to go after both Republicans
and Democrats who politically appointed
you so I don't think about it that way
you go after people without fear favor
without reference to what political
ideology they espouse what political
ideology you espouse whether they're
rich or poor powerful or not powerful
you mentioned by the way the the US
Attorney firings and I ran that
investigation actually in the Senate it
taught me a lot of things but you can't
politicize justice there's enough even
as we speak a regret I have is that
there's a lot of mistrust of law
enforcement and a healthy mistrust of
government and particularly people who
have a lot of power over people's lives
and power over people's Liberty like the
FBI has like US Attorney's have is very
important and good and part of why this
country is a great country because you
keep re-examining these things but it
becomes a terrible thing to the
institution of justice in the country if
people get a whiff that someone is
deciding to prosecute one party or
another now over time I've been accused
of all those things I've been accused of
being anti black because we arrested you
know an african-american person who was
prominent I've been accused of being
anti Russian I'm actually banned from
Russia
that's actually a fact I've been acute
I've been accused of being anti Asian
because we went after an Asian
politician and I've been accused of some
of you may know of being anti Indian
even though I my recollection is that I
was born in India so and at one point
accused of targeting Republicans and
another point accused of all sorts of
different things over time if you have a
long enough tenure you can show people
that if if you can be accused by every
ethnic group every demographic group
every political group that maybe you're
not anti any particular group you're
just anti-crime which I like to think
which I like to think that we are and so
you know for us it's not a question of
you know being fearful about going after
a democrat or republican you go after
the people you know you think her guilty
of crimes and that's what enhances
people's I think faith in the system so
two other types of crimes you've gone
after our financial fraud and cyber
crime um and these are very unique types
of crime and that the people that commit
them are highly sophisticated and they
tend to be always one step ahead of
regulatory agencies etc which are always
trying struggling to catch up maybe you
can kind of speak to this kind of
sophistication issue especially when it
comes to not only prosecuting the crime
but also identifying it and deterring it
and just kind of some of the challenges
you faced how we should do better as a
society dealing with this type of crime
yeah look it's a very hard thing and the
world is changing and part of the reason
I like coming to North Northern
California and and to Stanford is to
talk about the cyber issue the first
time I came out I did a whole session
with Professor grunt fest talking about
the issues of cybercrime it's nice that
it's now getting the kind of attention
that I think it deserves the president
talks about it the president's talking
about it here I think a week ago right
and and all the cabinet secretaries are
talking about it but it's difficult to
stay ahead I often joke people ask me
you know what
what does Preet mean it's an interesting
name obviously I tell them I'm from
India and and pre does in fact ancient
Sanskrit for cyber fighter so it's a
great coincidence the prop the problem
though is is that Barrera is also
ancient Sanskrit for could you help me
turn out my computer so joking aside the
there's there's that it sort of
encapsulates a problem for a law
enforcement right we have we have really
really smart people who care about the
issue in the FBI and the Secret Service
in other places and really smart
prosecutors particularly people who were
younger who are a little bit more
familiar with with how computers work
and how the internet works and how
cybercrime works but then you also have
incredibly sophisticated people who are
trying to take down networks and we're
trying to take down infrastructure and
trying to destroy America or at least on
the part of some folks just steal all
your bank accounts do money out of your
bank accounts so there's no easy answer
in the few minutes that we have to talk
about how you deal with that but you
deal with that in the same way you deal
with any other crisis that comes about
in the same way it's not that different
from how we try to deal with terrorism
particularly after 9/11 you try to
develop additional capacity you try to
going back to the thing I said at the
beginning you try to hire really smart
people who know what they're talking
about try to get people from industry to
come back part of the reason I'd like to
come out here also further what I said
before is to talk to people who know
these things and build partnerships
between the government and the private
sector and people who are much much more
attuned to how to keep Network secure
and how to keep computers secure and not
think that you know everything I mean
it's a humbling thing for the government
and people think the people in the
government walk around thinking they
know everything maybe some do but to the
extent that they ever thought that they
think that less now because the threat
is so difficult and so complicated not
only because it's it's difficult and
it's new stuff and it involves
technology which always freaks out older
people from the government it also
involves people who are perpetrating
offenses who are not only behind the
anonymity of the internet but also at a
great geographic remove often you know
thousands and thousands of miles away I
don't think there's any challenge it's
more difficult and worrisome than the
cyber challenge I just want to end with
a couple of very broad questions that I
think the students are very interested
in so one is when you see kind of
business role models and particularly in
finance a question kind of comes about
do I have to choose between being a
successful person and being an ethical
person do you think this is a legitimate
question or is this a false dichotomy
even though a lot of students think that
there's a line between choosing
success and levels of ethics yeah I
think it's a false choice I think
further what I said before that if
you're thinking in the longer term right
then you can you can and should do both
things it always pains someone to give
up a dollar today because they don't
know for a fact they're gonna make up
that dollar the next week by turning
down you know a questionable business
deal or choosing not to engage in a
questionable transaction but I just I
really do think based on my experience
that to do the right thing all the time
is what is ultimately going to give you
the reputation that will that will bring
you more riches both reputationally and
financially than you could possibly
imagine
it just is always true going back to a
question you asked me a minute ago about
how you choose to take things on you
know that there are people who I admire
who did difficult things one of them is
the current FBI director who at a time
when he's a Republican and it was out of
office testified very dramatically in
the Senate at a hearing that I arranged
about what had gone on with respect to
the terrorist surveillance program and
stopped the White House Council at the
time
Alberto Gonzales from overturning a
decision that Jim Comey had made when he
was the acting Attorney General and it's
very convoluted but the point is that in
the moment he did the right thing and
testified about something that was very
important and probably at the moment he
did that thought this is not gonna be
great for anything I might want to do in
the public in my future again Mary Jo
white and he's now the FBI director Mary
Jo white who hired me as the US Attorney
investigated the president who appointed
him who appointed her after Marc Rich
was pardoned by President Clinton also
probably thought this is the right thing
to do because this is my job and it's
not gonna further any career prospect I
have with the government or to be
appointed to anything in the future
again she's now the chairwoman of the
SEC I'm not saying that you that you do
things for those reasons but I just find
over time that if you act with integrity
and you and you take risk not because
you're trying to gain anything but it's
the right thing to do
people people generally will recognize
that and I think that's true in
government I think that's true in busy
and over the long term people are gonna
trust you to engage in in business deals
with you and if they think you're always
have some angle and you're always you
know trying to try to you know get over
on somebody in the long term that hurts
your earning potential I really think
that that's true and there's you
shouldn't have to choose between those
two things last question before I open
it up to the floor is this kind of idea
of corporate culture you've written
about it you've spoken about it it's
just a very nebulous thing to me it's
very vague concept but I think it is
very important um so I agree with all
the stuff you've written so in a more
concrete sense you know as these
students a lot of them go and start
companies they have to kind of develop
what the culture of their firms are
going to be what specific aspects of
corporate culture do you think are
crucial to building an ethical
organization how should they go about
thinking what aspects of their firm
promote a good culture yeah so I've
mentioned one already and a concern I
have a better culture of silence that
occurs at firms we are you have
environment in which bad things may be
happening but the culture is such that
people don't feel comfortable coming
forward and you need to have a place
when you're in charge of it or whatever
subdivision you end up being in charge
of you want to make sure that if
something bad is happening whether it's
related to an ethical problem or any
other problem for that matter I mean you
know we tend to overly separate issues
of ethics and issues of business and
another business risk you want to make
sure that that if if there's a
competitor who's making a better widget
than you are
that the boss doesn't know about know
that you don't know about is the boss
because you're not paying attention that
someone is not afraid of coming in your
office and saying you know by the way
we're gonna have a big competition
problem from these other widget makers
because they're making cooler widgets
than we are
you know that's called the I widget 6
and it's gonna crush us if you're a
blackberry for example in the same way
you want to create a culture in which
people are gonna come and tell you know
I have a little bit of a concern that we
have this unit that's playing fast and
loose and one day the SEC is gonna come
down on us like a like a ton of bricks
so you want to create a culture in which
that happens but the corollary to that
is on the silence issue is you want to
make sure you work in a place and that
you perpetuate this you work in a place
where people not only come forward but
someone does something about it
I think that's incredibly important I
think you said culture is a nebulous
I think it is in the same way that it's
hard to define what integrity is it's
hard to define what judgment is I've
tried for a long time it's a lot of
different things in some ways you know
when you see it in some ways you can
make a list of things and you to further
make this amorphous I will say that I
think another problem is there's too
much of a culture of formalism at places
so everyone's very smart one's very
rigorous you're all very analytical
which is why you got into business
school and I did not so you make
checklists of things and that's great
but sometimes you need to check your gut
not just check the box and so I you know
you have to apply common sense and you
have to think about what the principles
of good behavior are that you learned as
a child sometimes and not just do I do I
meet this regulatory requirement you
know to the letter and I get questions
sometimes that are that are surprising
to me something once asked me at the New
York Stock Exchange we had a group
together and we were talking about
issues that boards of directors have to
be concerned about and a very serious
person who advises members of boards to
worried me after she asked her question
was you know what percentage of time do
you think that you know a board member
of a member of the board or a c-suite
executive should spend thinking about
ethical issues I said well that's the
dumbest question I didn't say this I was
very polite it it depends obviously if
you are part of an organization or a
company that has had you know multiple
regulatory actions taken against you
eight people have been hauled off to
prison and you're being written about
every day as a disaster
you should probably spend a lot of time
thinking about ethical issues if on the
other hand you have you know a pristine
record and you're confident about your
systems you're confident about the
people you're hiring
there's been no enforcement action and
you're a model for integrity for
everyone else you can spend
proportionally less time so when you
talk about culture it's it it's part of
just keeping your eyes open and your
ears open and thinking about what makes
sense and just again re-emphasize a
point that I think you can't emphasize
enough it's not that different from
other business decisions that you make
well you know that person never would
have asked me imagine if somebody asked
me the question
or if you got to ask the question you
know can I ask you sir what percentage
of time do you think the CEO and the CFO
and the other strategic people at a
company should be thinking about
creativity what percentage of time
should be thinking about competition
well it depends on how much competition
you have it depends on whether or not
you think you're stagnating and you're
not being innovative anymore and the
same is true when you're talking about
ethical culture it depends on the
circumstances and I just worry after
doing this for a while that we have
these conversations and it becomes
people always ask me it becomes about
ethics and it becomes about legal policy
and it becomes about regulation when
really if you focus on judgment and you
focus on risk and you focus on on wisdom
and thoughtfulness that those are the
same principles you apply to everything
you do it shouldn't be any different
when you do we're not in some crazy
different realm on Mars it's the same as
everything else and the more people
think about it not as something that you
cabin separately oh it's thinks we got
talk about the ethics now all compliance
people it's just like everything else I
think everybody would do a better job
right thank you um just open it up to
the floor if anybody has any questions
or how we have the mic system thank you
very much for coming on for your
wonderful speech I have a question about
c-suite level convictions in jail time
there's been a lot of fuss in the press
made that yes you know apart from the
Galleon case that si si Mathew martoma
its convicted but you couldn't get Steve
Cohen or you know fabulous fabok Goldman
but you got no one in there C suite do
you see that as a problem is it
something that keeps you up at night
do you think that it's shifting of moral
hazard that these big firms just pay
fines and nobody actually goes to jail
and then they go back doing what they
did you know the next day and the next
week I don't lose sleep at night I sleep
fairly well look we have a system of law
in this country right and it's a
greatest system and people get
frustrated often if not everybody who
they think without knowing all the facts
and circumstances is not hauled off to
prison and our job always is to hold the
highest level person who's involved in
any bad conduct or in any institution
accountable if you can
you can't always do that you can't
always do that you know I used to do as
think was mentioned I used to do candy
no prosecutions and mob prosecutions it
can be difficult to go up the chain and
get people to be held accountable if
they deserve to be held accountable and
I'm not making an assumption there at
all is it frustrating sometimes when you
think that a person is guilty of a crime
you haven't been able to prove it
against them yeah of course but that's
not just so when you're talking about
the head of an institution like the ones
you mentioned if they were guilty of
something it's also true of the person
you think is guilty of a murder who's
not part of any organization because you
don't have the witnesses you don't have
a cooperating witness or you don't have
a wiretap or you don't have you know
some other kind of physical evidence so
there's always a frustration there
because you want to do what's right you
want to hold the right people
accountable and you want to get bad
people off the street so you know that's
how I think about that and you do the
best you can some from time to time
people say well we should lower the
standard to make it easier and to take
away you know the requirement that you
have a certain mental state that would
be a very dangerous thing because it
wouldn't just make it easier to charge
the few people who become you know
poster children for not having been
arrested and gotten you know jail free
cards it also becomes a prescription for
even ethical prosecutors to put a lot of
people in prison who you know maybe act
in good faith or made a mistake or were
negligent but did not have the proper
frame of mind or did not have knowledge
now there are a lot of people and heads
of institutions who are not blameless
even if you can't bring them you know to
court and try them and convict them and
send them to prison and I think that all
institutions where there have been
failures there's a level of
responsibility and blameworthiness on
the part of the management cuz even if
they even if they didn't know they
should have known now should have known
is not a standard that I'm allowed to
employ to send someone to prison for the
rest of their lives so that's just my
comment on the nature of the structure
of the system and the limitations of a
legal system in which you have to prove
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt and you
have to prove mental state the second
part of the question about whether or
not you worried that committing crimes
is just a part of doing business yeah
you worry about that all the time which
is why you try to make the penalty as
stiff as possible commensurate with the
conduct
that was committed the bad conduct that
was committed that will also deter and
it doesn't always work and I think
sometimes people people underestimate
the value of taking actions that don't
necessarily lead to everyone being
hauled off away in cuffs and that is
because we have a second interest not
just in holding people accountable and
in retribution we also also have
interest in reform and in a different
kind of deterrence so you can take an
action against a company like Toyota
Motor Corporation for example where we
levied at 1.2 billion dollar penalty
which was many times more than the
department transportation could levy
because of how they're playing games
with disclosures about safety problems
in their cars and an outside monitor and
a probationary period and a series of
reforms that were enacted at the company
so that the next time you're driving a
certain kind of car you can be more
assured that there's not a safety
problem with it now those things are not
always accomplish this by charging
somebody we had a session this morning
on Rikers Island we're taking all these
efforts against this prison which has
been a kind of a broken disaster in New
York for a number of years now and we're
doing both things we were bringing cases
against individuals who are corrections
officers who among other things caused
inmates to die using excessive
unconstitutional use of force against
them and sending them to prison and
that's great and that's holding them
accountable and hopefully deterring the
next corrections officer from from
beating the living daylights out of
somebody when you're not supposed to do
that separately we brought a suit
against the city and against the jail
system saying you have to adopt these
other institutional reforms because one
of the things that was going on and one
of the reasons why people were getting
away with these beatings was they were
not enough cameras in in the jail and
part of what we're hoping to negotiate
is the is the the putting in of hundreds
and hundreds of more cameras so the
corrections officers are gonna be less
likely to be able to get away with
unconstitutional excessive use of force
now I can charge as many corrections
officers as I want individually and send
them to prison that doesn't put another
camera in the ceiling that doesn't put a
camera in the recreational yard that
doesn't want a camera in in the medical
ward that requires the institution to
some responsibilities and to do some
things and so I've now segwayed into my
little homily about the issue I take
with some people including a particular
judges it's in my district who says
there is never any value in doing
something other than a prosecution of a
particular individual you can do a lot
of things and fix a lot of problems by
using other tools also I have a question
about a prosecutorial discretion a lot
of a professional furniture financial
firms cannot live with the indictment
that leaves a prosecutor's huge amount
of power overland that I just warned her
what you a prosecutor think about in
their thinking process any exercise in
that power in particular the destruction
of Arthur Andersen can mean mind which
job Arthur Andersen went down for a
conviction I was later overturned yeah
so I think people need to get over
Arthur Andersen a little bit that was
that was a long time ago and I think the
pendulum has swung too far in the other
direction and swinging back a little bit
now for a long time I would say that you
know people are overstating the risk to
to the institution from an indictment or
a guilty plea and that doesn't mean you
be irresponsible about it but it turns
out to be so last year that one of the
biggest cases brought in many many years
was my office's case against the npp
largest bank in France fourth largest
bank in the world they paid an almost
nine billion dollar fine they took a
guilty plea and I believe we are not a
nuclear winter I think not only are we
not a nuclear winter the company
survives and it was supposed to survive
because we were not trying to kill the
bank credit Swiss same thing I think
you'll see that happening a little bit
more
prosecutors are required should as a
general discretionary matter and also
required to under Department of Justice
guidelines to pay attention to
collateral consequences because yeah
because you don't want to you don't want
to cause a company to go out of business
it doesn't deserve to go out of business
where hundreds of thousands of
shareholders lose value we're a hundred
thousand employees may lose their jobs
as has happened in the past as you
mentioned unless that's your intent but
there are ways to do that if you're
responsible and if you're smart about it
so
I'm not really any secret but in
connection with the BNP P plea deal I
personally spend on other people on my
team spent a lot of time talking to the
Federal Reserve and the Department
Financial Services in New York and other
regulators including around the world in
Europe and in Asia to make sure that
everybody understood at the time we took
the action and force the guilty plea
because we thought that was the
appropriate result of all sorts of bath
money laundering activity that they
allowed to go on and I'm in sanctions
activity that they'll have to go on at
the end of the day I think it was a
seminal event in corporate prosecutions
we held an entire financial institution
accountable even though people said you
couldn't do that
we got a substantial penalty which is
not nothing I mean it's not just a cost
of doing business which I know nine
million dollars even to a bank of that
size is not pocket change and you get
reforms and you tell every other
similarly situated financial institution
in the world you better watch yourself
or this could happen to you also so to
me it was it was an achievement of of
rigorous tough but responsible
coordination among a lot of different
entities and it's one of the things I'm
most proud of because you can do that
and you can't hold people accountable if
it's done right thanks again for coming
this is a really interesting
conversation my question is around
ethics education at ethics in academia
you said it several times that to be a
good person to add on the doing the
right thing often times you learned that
when you're a kid and I've recently come
to realize some moments for myself is
that a lot of those things haven't been
updated since I was 12 13 14 years old
what to do to be a good person so my
question is that Stanford has taken some
steps to have ethics courses or great
introduction but what more do you think
should be done or can be done at
business school or even before that to
really get people to think for
themselves what their ethical framework
is going to be to make these decisions I
think I think the more you can have
conversations like this and the more
people can talk about actual scenarios
that you might get into so first you go
back to first principles do the right
thing that doesn't necessarily always
provide a lot of guidance unless you can
apply it to actual situations that you
might be in I would love to have people
talk in the business schools on a more
regular basis of
what are you gonna do the day you're
sitting there and you think something
bad has happened do you do you tell your
wife do you go to your shrink do you
have a cocktail do you tell your boss do
you go to the SEC you know what is it
that you do it's not that easy right so
when we say do the right thing
it sounds glib but I want to make sure
everyone understands they don't by any
means say that doing the right thing is
always the easy thing to do to turn in a
friend or to risk scorn from your
supervisors and your colleagues is
really really hard but I think what
fortifies you to do that is if you've if
you've thought about it in advance it's
like anything else you know cops train
before they're in an event where they
might be shot at you know troops train
quarterbacks train and part of the
training is to imagine scenarios that
you might find yourself in and not to
compare you know ethical behavior to
games but again oh all of being good at
something and all of reacting well in a
moment that's difficult
where there's adversity whether it's
because you know the team blitzed and
you didn't expect it or because all of a
sudden you think you got the raise
because someone thought you're going to
do something unethical that you've never
agreed to do it all requires thinking in
advance it requires you know
strategizing about it in advance and it
requires hearing from other people you
trust and respect that you should do
something about that when that happens
to you obviously you need to do other
things like people need to be educated
about what the laws are and what the
guidelines are I don't spend a lot of my
time talking about that because you know
what you could you can call you know the
counsel's office in your firm to figure
out what the law should be we have a lot
of regulations in this country and we
have a lot of rules and a lot of
policies but what I think people forget
about is is the basics the things you
learned when you're a kid is it right to
do or is it wrong to do and sometimes if
your gut tells you it's wrong to do or
it feels fishy to do but eight lawyers
tell you well technically if you do it
in this way and you make these
disclosures and you stick your head in
the sand with respect to these other
three facts you could probably get away
with it
you should aspire to a higher standard
than that
who come into the u.s. since I was a
teenager working in business I see that
actually the reputation sometimes of US
companies as I've suffered quite a bit
and the the issue is when you talk to
Germans for example there is this kind
of uneasiness about the spy scandal and
the way that sometimes the kind of us
chambers of commerce do not really come
out into the world with a really very
kind of ethical stance so in a way the
issues beyond ethics it's about
reputation of the United States so my
question is what can one do what can you
do
militarily you and you and and maybe you
would would you know we don't often I
think here you know the president United
States and other officials put emphasis
on how important for the US reputation
it is to have good businesses around the
world so I think it's it's a big issue
yeah I think everyone should talk about
reputation and and that goes a little
bit beyond then moralizing about you
know do the right thing and everyone
supposed to the right thing and eat your
vegetables there's a practical
consequence and bad reputation I think
part of the point of your remarks is
that it has a long-term business
implication for the companies also
because reputations are affected
adversely so I think you mean I try to
do it I talk about it in these groups
like this there's not a more influential
group going forward in this group I
think so yeah I endorse the idea that
people should be talking about these
things all the time and reputations are
important maybe a time for a lot to more
questions or one more one more question
okay so you talked about you talked a
lot about some of the challenges that
arise out of the complexity of financial
fraud and I was wondering obviously you
probably cannot reveal all the
information regarding to it but do you
see a lot of connection between the
world of finance and the world of
organized crime
you know not not you mean structural you
mean actual organized criminals engaging
in financial drugs we have both see from
titled the de menthe the mob exists I
get asked questions all the time about
the mob and I used to be a mop
prosecutor the mob is not engaged in as
serious violence as I think it used to I
think it got smart it figured out like a
lot of people maybe in this room that
you can make money doing you know
securities work that then then you can
you're doing you know fly-by-night
extortion schemes against restaurant
owners and in construction industry
people one of the biggest cases that was
brought in my office before I became the
US Attorney was I'm creating the name of
the operation there's a lot of people in
the mob who engage in a petty stock
fraud scam so you know wherever there's
an opportunity to make money through
fraud through extortion or through
something else the mob will figure out a
way to make money there and they think
they've done so here I don't think it's
it's I don't think it's a huge incursion
but they do some of it yeah thank you
great conversation I actually wanted to
bring up kind of says something that
ethically bothers me in in in the in
this situation where it's really the
millions and billions of dollars
involved and you actually touched it on
talking about the different companies
that you just want to be sure that the
company survived but do and there are
three different ways I look at it one is
where the money comes from when big
companies are fined or even private
equity firms which can come from
shareholders which can come from
endowments pension funds and is that
something you think about
and these ethically the the second point
is the hundreds of millions of dollars
of legal fees that are that are created
through these different prosecution's
and I'm for instance thinking about what
the press was saying about the the Bain
Capital Goldman Sachs settlements that
they settled because they didn't want to
pay another 200 million legal fees
anyway
and the last one is
how do you think about the ethics of
where these billions of dollars of fines
go and how they're used well let's back
to the third and I'll try to make a
quick send we're running out of time
there are two places they go when you
have a federal case one is if there are
victims identifiable victims they go to
the victims and I don't think for a
minute we're losing one second asleep
when we take money from people who based
on their misconduct whether their bad
conduct caused thousands of people to
lose their entire life savings because
of Bernie Madoff and so I'm very proud
of the fact that we've collected and
other people would have expected this I
think some people estimated about a
twenty billion dollar loss and some
people lost everything they had we've
collected in excess of ten or eleven
billion dollars and so every one every
penny of that goes back to the victim we
brought an enormous case against SAIC on
si si si I see which is a construction
company development company because he'd
afforded the city of New York to the
tune of a half a billion dollars and I
made them pay every penny back to the
city of New York which they could use to
hire firefighters and hire teachers and
so when they're identifiable victims of
a crime you get the money back so you
can give it back to the people who lost
the money when you don't have identify
identify identifiable victims we don't
keep any of the money it goes to the
general Treasury and Congress decides
how that money gets spent now there are
various things that you can do and I
think I appreciate the point you're
making with respect to whether or not
innocent parties are being made to bear
the brunt of some of these large fines
I'll quote from what Jim Comey said who
put it best when we brought a case
recently the current FBI director if the
shareholders are upset about that then
the shareholders should do something
about it and the shareholders should not
allow companies you know you know should
be angrier I shouldn't be the angry guy
the shareholders should be angry and the
shareholders should be demanding
sometimes the heads of the people who at
the top of these institutions who allow
the misconduct to happen such that those
fines are levy because I don't think
you're gonna find a lot of prosecutors
having sympathy for the idea that a lot
of and you can quibble about particular
cases and say well was this an
appropriate fine or not but but if it's
the case that people in their good
judgment believe that bad conduct
happened and there has to be a
discouragement of profit or there has to
be some lesson that's what what's called
a penalty that money has to come from
where otherwise the the logical extent
of the argument of complaint that money
is coming from shareholders is that you
walk away and do nothing and then the
next time by the way there could be a
worse action and the shareholders could
lose out worse or then another bank
could decide they're going to engage in
the same conduct and there'll be no
consequence at all I mean we've been
talking a little bit about whether or
not people think the paying of a certain
amount of fine is just a cost of doing
business
so I'm sometimes I sometimes worry that
there are actually people who think in
the opposite direction
that there shouldn't even be the cost of
doing business there shouldn't even be a
fine because it it unduly affects people
who you know you may be innocent
shareholders of companies that continue
to engage in bad conduct repeatedly are
not innocent in the sense I mean that
they're innocent in the criminal law
sense but but they should care about the
conduct of business at the institution
in a way that they provide the better
reforms you know it's a good point to
end on every once in a while people joke
and say that I'm the sheriff of Wall
Street or people in my position are the
sheriff's of Wall Street you know really
not there's actually very little that I
can do there's very little that
prosecutors can do because by the time
we show up everything has hit the fan
the companies have gone under people
been fired people have been arrested
that the real watchdogs who didn't do
their jobs in the first place are the
reasons that we exist when it comes to
financial institutions the boards of
directors didn't do their job the CEOs
didn't do their job their shareholders
didn't get upset and it is astonishing
to me when I hear people who are
shareholders of companies who are
complaining more about the fine then
about the conduct that led to the fine
and I see over and over again when
people come in don't do this when you
represent a company who come in and say
you know we really don't deserve the
fine we don't deserve to be prosecuted
we really don't deserve this result and
I say well you know what happened to all
the people who are responsible when
these bad things and they'll acknowledge
bad things happen mistakes were made and
so what happened to them and you know
how often I'm told including with banks
whose initials may or may not include I
won't say you got me you got me on a
rant um and and I say what happened this
person promoted what happened this
person promoted was anybody fired no and
going back to a point I was making about
the disc
and how we're on Mars when we talked
about compliance and enforcement and
ethics as opposed to everything else it
continues to become astonishing to me
you would never say imagine imagine the
Board of Directors saying to the CEO of
a company well what you know what
happened to that division we totally
screwed up the strategic plan we are far
behind on everything we expected to do
whatever your business is in and saying
we failed we failed we failed we failed
know what I'm saying they engaged in
criminal activity but we failed the
people who are in charge fail to have
the place act well and the CEO said well
they all got promoted how long would
that CEO be in charge and I see over and
over again that there's no consequence
internally within the company and look I
can start taking the position and some
people have suggested that we should
that we should start dictating to
companies that people get fired and
their bonuses get clawed back and
there's some state attorneys general who
are thinking about doing this I don't
want to run people's businesses for them
but it is really up to the people in the
company as the firt in the first
instance to be the watchdogs of good
behavior there and then you know we
could do terrorism work and other things
that are more fun to do sometimes but I
appreciate your point but but I think I
think there's a lot of blame that goes
around and people need to think really
hard about their own roles in either
being enablers or passive acceptors of
bad conduct it goes on and firms okay
thank you so much
you